I thought we'd do two main sets of
things I want to talk to you about your
signature culture because I think it is
so interesting to all of us and then at
some point we'll pivot from that into
talking a little bit more generally
about leadership leadership style and
how you approach leadership and then
we'll leave some time for questions from
the audience and we'll wrap up at the
end so talk to me about you know some of
these signature pieces of the culture
that I refer to in my in my opening
remarks that the idea of mayor and
village and teammates you know the
dress-up the chanting that I hope that I
heard backstage what's the story behind
behind all of this yeah so we we believe
we're a community first in a company
second and hopefully everybody has some
communities that they're a part of in
their life could be their family could
be the book club could be their church
could be the sports team could be their
best friends the community basically
means that people care about each other
respect each other and they care about
the organization that they're a part of
that they're stewards that care about
what they give on to the next generation
that that's basic concept of community
and and so we believe in that fervently
that that given we spend more than 50%
of our waking hours as an adult at work
and for some of us it's way more than
50% especially if you travel that to
concede that in any way that shouldn't
be central to your life mission and that
you shouldn't be emotionally engaged
with the people that you work with all
that time we think is a grotesque
concession that that some people have to
make and and a lot of people don't have
to when people like the ones in this
room are going to have a spectacularly
big impact on the folks that work for
you through the course of your life and
so so we we said okay we're going to be
a community alkkagi community let's call
it a village let's make it the mayor
because that raises the bar of expected
behavior for us and so we we take it
very seriously when we make decisions we
consistently use the metaphor if you
were mayor of a village how would you
decide because if you're mayor of a
village you care about
the economy but the economy is the means
to an end it's not the end you want to
help the economy so you can have good
schools good parks etc yeah so I have to
say I mean I alluded to you know what
happened in the green room before but it
but it is very impressive I mean so here
you are meeting up with a bunch of folks
from you know the local area who you
don't do this with every day and yet you
were able to lead them through a series
of chairs which are clearly deeply
ingrained and and done as you can see by
just looking around the room with you
know with this with a sense of passion
and buy-in which of course is critical
to having called we can talk about
culture all we like but but getting it
bored in in that way deeply through a
fortune 500 company I mean that's tough
so can you tell us a little bit how do
you go about that how do you do that
it was well first this teammates stand
up what the heck we got some teammates
here so so
I knew I knew they were gonna be a
couple here but I didn't know be a bunch
and so there's a pleasant surprise right
before so I will ask them three
questions stay standing did what is this
company whose company is it and what
could it be and if we're to build the
greatest self care community the world
has ever seen let it be like this one
for all damn straight
so that this part wasn't conscious when
we started this adventure and it kind of
popped up organically and what we find
is that healthy tribes military units
religions sports teams places that have
strong sense of team strong as its
community they do call in response a
language means something ritual means
something and so we said if we're going
to be a community we should have the
attributes of a healthy religion tribe
village and it turns out calling
responses is what happens naturally in
those quarters doesn't happen naturally
most most companies because they're sort
of morally sterile no no value judgment
implies there yet I said sort of so um I
mean it's it is it is pretty amazing to
watch but how do you how do you know
that works I mean I obviously you know
it works in that you're able to
perpetuate it but how do you know that
you're distinctive because of it how do
you know that you're getting superior
results because of it yeah so so we were
very metric oriented and if you're if
you're gonna be serious about being
community you got to be objective and we
certainly not all of our neighborhoods
are happy neighborhoods but but our
clinical outcomes are superior to our
competition that government just came
out with a new rating system for example
only 30% of all the centers in America
and dialysis which is one of our two big
businesses can be ranked of four or five
and that the percentage of our centers
that are in that those four or five
categories is twice as high as any
competitor so it's a crushing example in
addition we did an acquisition about a
three billion dollar acquisition X years
ago we pay we do the analysis our wages
were the same or salaries are the same
we were in all the same geographies
across America their turnover was 40%
higher so they they they we were then we
would had to hire an extra 1200 people a
year compared to what we had to do give
them the difference in retention at the
same pay across America and third
there's some of the big consulting firms
Anne's the Hewitt's that do standard
questions across big companies and our
teammate engagement scores are quite
high and then I'll give one anecdote
about five six years in a woman came up
to me at a big conference and said
they've been hired by a pharmaceutical
company to do focus groups with patients
and they had never worked for us they
were never going to work for us and and
she said by the third city we were
playing a game because that's what you
have a facilitator and then and then the
sponsors are behind a mirror looking at
the people and then the 15 patients
answering these questions just like they
do with cars and toothpaste and and all
that and I said by the third city we
played a game that about 40 minutes in
since they didn't ask the question of do
you know who owns and operates your
dialysis center until the very end about
40 minutes into it they play a game and
guess which patients for the divita
patients because you could tell that
they talk differently and this at this
point was across a thousand different
locations small locations across America
that was for us one of the separate for
all those hard metrics that was perhaps
the most special one that human beings
talked differently so you spoke a little
bit about some acquisitions and
spreading culture through acquisitions
and the one that you refer to is one
where it was really a like business
model but you would you were taking the
culture to that and of course you know a
couple years ago you you bought HPC
which is in a quite different business
related but different business and so
have you tried to take the same culture
there are they limits to the extent to
which you can transfer the culture -
yeah well both the big dialysis company
when we bought them they were horrified
at the notion of being subjected to this
weird [ __ ] you know they yet yeah that
they said it looks like a call that's a
technical term yes yes a term it's a
just quoting them
the that that seems like a cult
it seems sophomoric it seems cheesy it
seems inappropriate Cavalier and both
there and then with this related
business three years ago they were
similarly worried about about being
subjected to a force to try to adopt it
we made very clear within rooms like
this only not as nice we can't afford
nice rooms like this the make very clear
please don't use our language unless and
until it becomes comfortable that don't
don't don't talk about I don't feel like
you have to talk about our values or
some of our concepts or the village
don't twenty that get to know us watch
how we behave watch how we interact and
then a year downstream we'll talk about
one night we need to change any of the
values or whatever and both the first
time in the second time legacy the Vita
veterans were appalled that I would say
that we might change them but my
response was if you're a village you
have to represent the current population
and and when you have a lot of new
people it's a new thing and you need to
speak for that new community and in the
case of this related acquisition that
from a business point of view the first
two years went very poorly tremendous
organizational change we took out half
the senior executives so a relatively
traumatized organization which
exacerbated the fear around you know one
hell of a village you know you let half
the people go and you're introducing all
this change and so in the second
nationwide meeting since the time we
close the deal once here we get our top
four thousand liters or so together I
went off in a room with the two hundred
seventy leaders from that enterprise 18
months in traumatic eighteen months and
said okay now we're going to have a
debate do you want to go adopt the
legacy divita vision mission and values
do you want to keep what you have wait
another year keep it forever or
somewhere in between and it was a very
intense debate about about 80 out of the
250 people or so were physicians people
from all over America knew somewhere new
to the enterprise because the
acquisitions have been in post close
somewhat been there 25 years they went
through it and and about halfway through
a woman stood up and was a variant
debate a woman stood up one thing we
didn't have on the ballot was go all in
to take take the vision mission and
values we put you can take these two of
these two or just one or none because we
never thought it would go all in well
this one woman stood up and said you
know what you know I've been I've been
now it's been a year and a half since
the deal this we have wonderful people
in our company health care partners they
have wonderful people in Legacy divita
they are living the values that we all
agree with with far more intentionality
and follow-through and purpose and
robustness than we are and I want to be
one company I vote for all in I think
that should be added to the ballot
applause broke out in the room we had
another hour of debate both in small
groups and big groups and at the end of
that two and a half hours the two
hundred sixty or so leaders from that
enterprise voted 85% to go all in 14 of
the remaining 15 voted to go 2/3 of the
way in only 1% voted so so they they
voted for embraced the village concept
themselves much I think to their own
surprise no one knew what the outcome
was going to be going into that room and
therefore there was no one subjected to
anything and they went out and told
everybody across America that we just
you know I've sort of taken this stuff
more seriously now and in fact I just
voted for it and has it taken root I'd
say you know the math I use as I think
we're about one third teammates citizens
maybe more maybe 33 to 40 percent
what about 30 35 percent you know just
still watching observing and then
whatever number is left are still
negative yeah so it's still on the
subject of exporting the culture you've
taken davido now internationally can you
talk a little bit about some of the
challenges and in taking this kind of
corporate culture to other other
national cultures yeah the this has been
it's been very intense the so first when
you think about core values some people
will look at them on a wall and say yeah
it's motherhood and apple pie who
doesn't believe in integrity who doesn't
believe in team what a dumb
pointless list everybody believes in
them as a leader the issue is not belief
it's practice so yeah I believe in all
those things if you evaluate exactly how
I behave every day some people would say
hey Kati I'm not so sure you're living
that core value that you believe in and
even harder to create an environment
where everybody practices them and and
not violating a core value does not
equal living it so if I go a month
without telling a lie that is not living
a life of integrity living a life of
integrity is when you tell the truth
when it hurts when it's embarrassing we
didn't have to if I go a month without
blaming someone for something they
didn't do I'm not living the core value
of accountability living the core value
accountability is when someone makes a
mistake and no one thinks you had
anything to do with it and you realize
that you knew the person wasn't very
good about that you could have taken him
aside two weeks ago for half an hour
they never would have made the mistake
and you stand up and take accountability
because you said you know what I could
have prevented that I know Josh was
uncertain or whatever and so there's a
big difference between not violating and
living and it's contagious how that
works
and so internationally when we decided
to go if I was a better CEO we would
have gone international ten years ago
but I wasn't so we started four years
ago and I went to other CEO I was from
prestigious business schools like
Stanford and and they all said you know
that that weird stuff you do leave it at
the airport
because you know it's unusual even in
America so don't you dare try to do it
in Saudi Arabia don't you dare try to do
it in China etc etc Poland Portugal
Colombia they made all these that India
all these other places we are so I took
their advice and and then I was giving a
talk to a bunch of our Indian teammates
X months later as we began to grow and
it just felt totally flat and so I went
to the boss after I knew enough he was
honest he gave me that gift I said well
that would've really fell flat and he
said they they've all been on the
Internet
they if you go walk around their
cubicles they've got the divita symbols
up they've got the story of how our
neighborhood has grown within the
context and now they're feeling like
this village thing that's just about
America and they're not really citizens
they're just you know foreign laborers
and so which I was mailed back we
changed
we went full on and and in doing that
you find out that it's about human
values that everyone wants to have a
robust discussion around actual human
values and what or not they're used in
making day-to-day business decisions or
not it's not a fairytale thing and and
we've had uncomfortable moments in some
of the cultures as we work through in
particular for example because we won't
stand for some of the gender
discrimination that exists in a lot of
other societies and that leads to
awkwardness and then one other moment of
awkwardness and then I'll stop the so
you trying to get the right translation
is not always straightforward um and and
so it turns out in one country the word
that we were using for fulfillment
basically means masturbation and and so
we were saying you know fulfillments
very important we think everyone should
be fulfilled you know even we hold our
leaders accountable for fulfillment and
and then someone gave the speaker was
not me the gift of so there are speed
bumps in the way and you had metrics
today back yesterday so I mean probably
true of your of your days at Bain but
when we teach strategy we talk of course
about alignment between between
organization including culture and and
strategy but then we also talk about
alignment between that and the external
environment that you find yourself in
industry and so on so so the question
really is how general do you think this
kind of the applicability of this kind
of culture is I mean is is this
something that works in in mission
driven health care mission driven kinds
of industries is something that you
think could be applied more broadly what
are the limits this one this is one
where we're quite intense because a lot
of people will kind of go oh they're
nice little health care service people
you know I'm sure it'd be very very
pleasant to talk to but they probably
lose all their football games and in
week over the last 16 years they're in
the top 5% of new york stock exchange
performers
we outperform our competition and
clinical outcomes and a lot of our
teammates have gone on to be CEOs and
CIOs lots of other companies so we we we
don't think there's any tension between
achieving capitalistic and market-based
and net worth ambitions and creating a
healthy and distinctive community for
people to work we think there's no no
tension between those in fact we think
they're in some ways cohabitate very
positively and so if I was running an
enterprise with 3000 taco bell's not not
medical clinics or a coal mine or any it
is all about creating a differentially
healthy environment for people to work
particularly the people that don't have
the career options and income and
flexibility that that most of us in this
room have that that that that applies to
any business that we a healthy workplace
is a gift to that mommy or that daddy
that they will take home it is a gift
that they will savor at work and it's
about basic ways in which humans behave
with one another so we believe
passionately that it's transferable
everywhere that's not to say that there
aren't differences in how one would
implement how it manifests itself in a
in a Goldman Sachs or a Bain & Company
or versus the other organizations that
the Democrat that the demographics of
the citizenship does affect it but the
basic principles have to do with how we
behave with one another and what not
it's consistent with them with the
values that we allege to hold dear and
so I'd like to start to transition to
leadership I keep keep one footing
culture and put put one foot in in
leadership so you know some of the
things that we're talking about village
mayor community you know sound sounds
soft they sound that sound soft they
sound a little bit squishy very GSB
esque actually um we're always going to
say it yeah we're we're also heavily
into into costumes which you call
uniforms so see a parallel there as well
but at the end of the day you're the CEO
of a fortune 500 company and that's a
tough role that requires tough decision
making it requires holding people
accountable you know that doesn't sound
so soft and squishy actually and so I'm
just wondering how how much of this
translates into your your day to day job
how do you how do you think about that
and and and Elizabeth some point the
video is ready we can play it the okay
didn't okay the it's I think it's where
the metaphor comes in so handy if if
you're the mayor of a village everyone
knows the village has to have a healthy
economy in order to create jobs for
people to have everybody knows you got
to pay taxes to support the school
system and the police which so and but
there's serious issues of who should pay
how much tax how transparent is the
deployment of the tax funds that are
raised how competent are the
organizations that spend the tax money
and so we think of profits to the
shareholder like that so we're very open
about it that that we don't get to
create the Davidi university that our
people love with a tremendous emphasis
on personal reflection and introspection
not just applied stuff we don't get to
grow and create career opportunities we
don't get to grow and create profit
sharing Awards and unless we are
allocated capital which is just like a
mayor's got to collect tax money in
order to do all the things that citizens
want to exist the parks and the summer
programs and so you and we find that
that it doesn't matter wave 18,000 folks
out of our sixty five thousand if not
been to college and never will they
understand the concepts totally about
what real life is like if they feel
you're honest and transparent about what
reality is and are willing to have real
debates so I've gotten up in front of
thousands of our teammates and talked
about my compensation an executive
compensation with people making $17 an
hour and then they get the right to ask
questions or send send messages so so
first there's there's an issue of the of
just basic straightforward honesty and
transparency and explanation to kind of
loop things together in a way that that
otherwise doesn't work and then second
when we talk about tough to say
we we will discuss them in the context
of the metaphor give one example we made
that big acquisition referred to well
the government was appropriately going
to requires to do some divestiture z'
and when you do divestiture z' but the
FTC requires is that you either either
divest all the defeated legacy to be
dissenters or all of the new companies
you can't pick and choose because you
would cherry-pick all the best market
positions and so you can't do that it's
it's a reasonable federal policy
everybody assumed in the I mean
everybody assumed that that I would
decide to divest all centers from the
company we were buying and some of these
folks would have been in in this part of
this and and I said no if if the other
company that we're buying has got a
group that's on the ascendancy that is
the clear long-term winner then we will
divest the divita legacy to be
dissenters people were appalled that you
know this is a violation we love the
village we've been good citizens the
village of excellent clinical outcomes
and you're going to sell us too you
don't even know who you're going to sell
it to and we can't even switch and work
because the way the FTC rules work you
can't you know take all the employees
you got to add a certain hands-off
period and our case teammates on
employees they call them employees and
so people are livid and I got up in a
room a bigger room with 3,000 of our
leaders and explained that that job one
of a mayor of a village is to make sure
the village is sustainable for the long
term because every single one of us
talking to them is going to leave the
village at some time because we get a
great job offer because we retire
because their spouse gets transferred
and so we are all stewards for the next
set of people in these chairs and for
maintaining an environment where we can
provide superb care for our patients
that's job one and just like if you're
mayor of a village and you know you got
to put a highway in or your downtown's
going to deteriorate and you're going to
lose to some other village you know you
got to rip down houses to put in that
highway and some of those people will
have lived in those houses for 25 years
love their neighborhood and you're gonna
rip down their house to put in a
frigging highway but that's the right
thing either that or the place goes dead
in 30 years
got up and and explained why I had
decided what I decided and about 70
percent of the people being divested
came up after most of them crying saying
that they they accepted the logic that
the decision was best for the village
and it was consistent with my
responsibility and they were very sad
but understood so so we it's we put it
together because life life yeah it's
hard sometimes and and how much of this
translates to decision-making with your
core team I mean are you're talking
about the the village at large but when
you bring this back to core management
II mater what are some of the tough
decisions you made are they are they
times where you've had to go against the
wisdom of the core team and say yeah you
know I am the mayor and this I think
this is the this is the right decision
yeah they've been a couple we do a lot
of votes compared to most organizations
votes with thousands of people involved
sometimes hundreds of people involved
but I always retain the the right to
overrule the vote I mean it's the
discussion that matters and the data is
very useful for me and for others but in
the end I have the job I have that
should come with differential inside and
and should carry with it a
differentiated experience some people
would question that it's and and so we
had one one business that that I wanted
to buy and the entire team voted against
it so I hired Vayne and then they came
out and recommended against it so we
stopped that project and and I told I
pulled out of the process and then I
went on that weekend and I just said our
alleged vision at that point because we
were just kidney care at that point was
to transform kidney care in America
which were halfway there and this was 13
years ago and we cannot get that we
cannot seriously try to do that unless
we buy this thing even though right now
it's little and broken and there's no
pro forma you can do that makes sense
that we have to change a bunch of laws
to do a lot of things and I went back on
on Monday and and
all the team we're going to buy it and I
respect all the reasons but it's not
it's not inconsistent with our construct
and then I guess the other part if it
was implicit in the question about core
team if the I am sensitive to the fact
that that there are times that I behave
in ways that are inconsistent with our
mission and values and particular with
my core team when you say bring it back
to that
mm-hm and and that is where one hopes
that you've scored enough points in
terms of intentionality that people
forgive you for your behavioral
transactional shortcomings do they call
you on it do they feel comfortable
enough to call you on it dude you
apologize for it how do how does that go
I'd say that's a big curious but some of
the teammates say the I think we're
we're seriously above average and people
being willing to call us on it
I get scored in the core values every
year an independent consultant goes out
and talks to a lot of folks my scores
are made public to the board and to the
teammates as well as a bunch of comments
I don't get to change them IND and then
we'll talk about high and low scores we
we take as it sort of self-evident that
that that we all have bad stretches that
we all have faults and and that if you
can't create an environment where you
talk about them each of our personal
growth journeys are going to be stunted
and so we do a lot of introspection a
lot of reflection a lot of discussion
and in the second part of every
executives review is after I for example
when I'm reviewing others the first part
is the most important message the second
part is to go through each core value
and talk about how other people's
experience you with respective integrity
how do they experience to you with
respect to fun how do they experience
you with respect to service excellence
real words and so and then I get the
same back so I think we we help me and
we help each other grow as human beings
and so I think we're we're reasonable on
that so where most of the first years
have been taking a course here which we
call leadership labs one of the things
we talk to them about in the labs is is
being active learners and being active
learners they hold their whole lives
their whole careers
you constantly learn from what went well
what didn't go well become become a
better manager leader your spoking about
some of the ways you're getting feedback
but but what are some of the other ways
that you personally have worked on your
own leadership and management skill over
time well so so one of our pitter
patters is management is a business
skill it's really important so you
should study it and think rigorously
about it leadership is a human thing not
a business thing and if you want to give
better at leadership learn more about
humans starting with yourself and so
virtually every W University class has
elements of introspection and
self-reflection and and particularly if
you have as have as many behavioral
deficiencies as I have you we try to
make sure not just through 360 process
but through using other tools and
outside coaches that you're continuously
forced to reflect on your self and and
and that combined with having to discuss
yourself publicly is a is a tremendous
spirt thing that can spur your your
growth for me to work on some of my
behavioral things I have done things
like give myself a score every day so
when I took this job 16 years ago is 43
when you still have serious behavioral
issues which many of you will have it
doesn't mean you're a bad person and
overall I got some good scores but I had
things I had to work on when you're 43
you better see yo already for eight
years this means there's some stuff
going on I mean you're not just going to
get their feedback and then suddenly the
next day stop entirely and so for some
of those things I use the metaphor of
it's my brother's is an alcoholic he's
now 11 years sober and he talks about
the early years
he said you know I had to win that
battle against alcoholism everyday and
so for some of my behavioral
deficiencies like getting angry with
people I started giving myself a daily
score and tracked it on a spreadsheet
because I I had to build the muscle
memory to to catch myself first after I
did it and then I could go apologize if
I had the courage and then catch myself
while I was doing it and and then catch
myself right before I was going to do it
and and after about two years I was
doing it a lot less but if I had not
kept the daily score to confront my
reality while it was still fresh and I
couldn't then just sort of consistently
dismiss it as you know as a bad day or
the person you know has been bugging me
for a while then all the
rationalizations get stripped away when
you score yourself every day did you
have a drink or not did you have too
many drinks or not it just is the
reality it is you it's not the external
world fascinating I want to go back a
little bit in your career because I
think it's of interest to the student
bodies they're thinking about you know
where to go way to go next from from the
GSB you did spend a good spell at Bain
there's there's a lot you learn in in a
gig like that
and I'm wondering about the transition
from that to being CEO of an operating
company what did you learn at Bain that
was helpful other some things you you
learnt at Bain that you that you had to
unlearn you can talk a little bit about
better transition first of all as to
ideas for where you should go after
Business School I have have one they
have but we'll come back to that the on
the Bain versus operating company thing
back when I graduated which was a long
time ago there at that in that decade in
my mind there weren't really a lot of
operating companies that had thoughtful
programs for growing general managers
and leaders and that's that's what we're
about and that's what I wanted to become
I knew my dream was to become
of competent general manager and leader
of people that's I knew that's what I
wanted to become proficient at and and I
did not I did not see stuff like there
were jobs out there but they they
weren't about that they were they were
just about learning the business and and
then and consulting more generally in my
way I would advise young people is if if
you want to be a general manager leader
in the long term that and you find
you're the sort of person who's super
super bright you figure out the case
faster than other people you can you can
be very verbally adroit connected to
your brain that but you're not a natural
team leader you're not an actor you're
not a natural team builder you're not
naturally establishing trust well you
got to stare at that very realistically
because if you want to be gym a leader
and you have that mix relative to the
world doesn't you know there's no good
or bad in this and you go to consulting
or vessel banking that you your existing
muscles get way way stronger and your
pay goes up and these other muscles stay
weak and then you want to make a shift
and it's a nightmare because you got to
take a huge cut and pay and work on your
remedial capabilities and so you don't
do it and I got a lot of friends who are
59 and wealthy and not happy because
they they went too much they didn't have
a good strategy
similarly if if you're graded that
project management and team leadership
and the rest which I felt for me that
was of some of my natural natural sport
for me a lot to learn but a natural
sport but you need help and more
strategic discipline more analytical
discipline we need to just be exposed to
a lot more then it goes the other way
that you know you're going there and
getting that incredible exposure in
learning those disciplines and then you
transfer over to a sport you were sort
of born to play and and so I think it's
very there's no generic answer it's very
person specific and it requires
incredible intellectual honesty about
your strengths and weaknesses and and
where you want to end up and so for me I
needed I needed exposure
I needed to to run with that that sort
of intellect with people for a while to
make me sharper help me grow I needed to
become more disciplined analytically I
needed all those things and I got them
big time and then went to play where I
always knew I mean the sport I wanted to
play thank you I don't want I don't want
to hug all your time let's let's instead
open it up for for questions from from
the audience I have the first question
from Twitter how do you distinguish
company as community from company as a
family how does one for instance fire a
community member
oh yeah actually when you asked about
tough moments firing a friend and in
some cases someone you literally love is
a brutal thing to have to do in ticki if
they love the village and you have that
personal relationship and then you tell
them they have to go and and and we use
community which of course is made up of
families very explicitly because the
family thing while there that level of
intimacy exists in some of our
neighborhoods and some of our smaller
teams for us some of the my senior
executive team we we love each other as
we love our oldest dearest friends and
we talk about it and and so we are
almost like families but for the bear
community that'd be an overly aggressive
word it would just be inaccurate to say
the entire 65,000 people across 12
countries is a family it just it would
be an appropriate metaphor the dislike a
village has families within it that's
that's that's just more accurate we're
serious about the metaphor if you're
going to if it's going to if it's going
to help you make decisions and help you
talk about decisions and help people
understand how you want to behave it's
got to be real it's got to make sense
has got to be internally holistically
consistent and so the ones there we I'm
much better at this I used to be bad at
giving people bad reviews and bad at
terminating because that was too intent
on proving I was right I'm right about
the way he underperform
I'm right about it's the right decision
to terminate you and then and then one
of my executives to work for me a guy
named Tom muscle ttan taught me what I
thought about conceptually but had never
applied to that area which is the whole
issue of intentionality until I got to
the point where I intended to be helpful
to that person in the review or in the
decision helpful
I could never become very good at doing
it and as I went through my year two of
learning that from this gentleman I
there were times I cancelled the meeting
because I knew I was still going in with
my old tendency to want to prove I was
right and and and take care of respond
to any rebuttal and so if you go into it
with the right intention in your heart
your head will do just fine by itself
and in a in a village you got to
maintain the health of the village and
doesn't mean they're going to be
destroyed there's there are their jobs
there are their villages in many cases
they're people who won't take a demotion
and so in that case it becomes their own
decision to go it turns out a majority
of successful executives have a really
hard time with a demotion I think that's
totally philosophically inappropriate
and shallow the but it's where most
human beings come from shell is not the
right word but I think in many cases
they would have been happier but but I
think putting in the right context
having the right intentionality and then
being respectful inhumane okay my name
is fernanda i would like to hear a
little bit more about the intentional
parts of the culture so in the beginning
here you were saying or what we just did
that was not my intent when we started
off and I'm sure a lot of things evolved
through the years but I would like to
hear about your vision in the very
beginning and your role as a leader and
making that vision come true yeah I mean
let me take a stab at it and then you
come back if I don't hit it right an
intentionality is is fundamental and we
just for exam for ten people last night
in Denver who just went through
something that I'll describe as part of
our intentionality and that was the
first word they used there a couple big
groups that are thinking of joining us
and and when that happens we just invite
them to come to our big meetings so so a
Part A and A Part B first when I showed
up and they were in for reasons we can
go into later perhaps it was a big big
big family decision I did announce to
the to the groups like this that that
number one I wanted to create a
differentially healthy place for people
to work and I have an unusual percentage
of people say that it was the best place
they ever worked not perfect not easy
but the best place ever worked and
number two is willing to build the
greatest dialysis company the world ever
seen that that that's what I said and we
were on the verge of bankruptcy we're
being investigated by the SEC we're
being sued by shareholders we had no CEO
no CEO and the CFO we were in six weeks
of missing payroll on 9,000 people and
and and so when I said those words in
that situation a lot of people thought
it was inappropriate emphasis given
where we were and in my mind if you care
about that stuff that time to start
working on it is right now you never
delay doesn't mean you don't know you
have to do all the other stuff there's
no such thing the leaders lead they
don't wait for the right time to lead
second when I did that yeah we use this
room the 1/3 of the people thought it
was just you know manipulation
superficial marketing you know
hoity-toity MBA wants us to stay looks
like we're going to go bankrupt so this
is like you know what he would if he
wants us to stay you shouldn't give us
you know superficial football speeches
like that he should give us retention
bonuses and then maybe a third of the
group obviously don't know the right
numbers we're thinking well that's very
nice he seems sincere but that'll last
about a month and then maybe a third of
the group said wow I would like to work
in a place that's differentially healthy
place for human beings to work and has a
dream of actually making a significant
impact on the world I would I'd like
that I'm hoping he's sincere and he's
competent and
and if you have not done it yet given a
speech in room where two-thirds of the
people think you're full of it it's not
fun it's not fun but it demonstrates
intentionality and then and then you say
and by the way I know most of people in
the room think this is not pragmatic or
not sincere or naive or whatever and
then they go look at like so he actually
knows that a bunch of us think its BS
and he's still saying it now that's
interesting because at first we just
thought he was dumb or naive now we see
he actually knows and he's still saying
it and and then and then people of
course say how it's okay that's what we
had to figure out together yeah here's
some ideas about about our policies
around 2vd University here's some our
policy about helping teammates in need
here's some are here some of our here's
some brainstorming here and there on
personal professional development and
impact on communities and and and and so
we started to demonstrate by having
regular meetings where the only subject
was how do we make this notion of being
a differentially healthy place to work
come true and and just like if you had a
marketing problem or a manufacturing
problem you it was the agenda item you
would generate ideas you would allocate
resources you would have programs you
would monitor the execution so we we
respected the challenge and we
demonstrated that we were damn serious
about it and and we used to get the
phone as we still do every eight weeks
for a voice to the village call they're
just on one yesterday about five
thousand people across the world and in
those days every call I'd say what is
the incremental evidence since the last
call to suggest we're serious about this
mission and values stuff and so and so
put it way way out there and then at
some point you call the question and say
okay you know that we call it crossing
the bridge and we have a bridge in every
neighborhood I walk across the bridge
every morning and if you after you've
been with us six months we ask you to
stand at that bridge and and decide you
never have to tell us and if you decide
to walk across it it means that you've
declared that you share accountability
for creating a differentially healthy
place to work having us be a community
first and trying to have a differential
impact on health care in the world and
so and so it was very explicit it was
very much reinforced by actual actions
actual intellectual investment actual
project management operating follow
through actual honest discussions about
how we were doing because back then we
had nine thousand people across 450
locations if you didn't get way intense
it's not like being able to call
everybody in a room it had to be much
more serious so I think those are some
of the things that really hammered home
the intentionality and and got a lot of
people thinking about what not they
wanted to cross the bridge and then I'll
throw out one other thing that was
powerful part of it a bunch of managers
in the first year across the bridge they
said whoa we we believe this and we're
we're psyched it would be great to
retire and say I tried to build the
greatest dialysis company we'll ever
seen and have a different idea I'm on
board but when I go back to Tulsa or New
York or whatever and talk to the 25
people in my little Center
I can't bring that alive and we're open
six days a week three ships a day I
can't even put my team together much
less convey at all and the video is help
but they're not enough and so we're like
you know that the village concept is
sort of stopping at the manager level
and so we hit town halls and their
managers saying this to me and the other
senior leaders and I said okay how can
we break through that and then somebody
had the you know temerity to say well
you know we couldn't actually fly all
our people somewhere like to go to
meetings like we do and discuss this
stuff and you know of course no you
can't because it's expensive and because
it's really hard to get substitute
staffing and all the local centers and
and then we said okay but it appears we
can't we can't do it we say we want to
do the dream is not feasible unless
we're willing to do something that we
don't know of anyone else that does and
so ever since that time we have
academies or two days long every
teammate in America and now increasing
the world is invited to come for two
days we have people who've never been in
a business trip lots of them some never
been on a plane don't have credit cards
never checked into a hotel and then the
vice president's right next to the
doctor is right next to the they the
tech who's right next to the secretary
and it's two days with no applied
training it's all about our mission our
vision our language our rituals people
go through things like Meyers bread
and we have thousands of people have
never done that and the second day we
asked everyone to write their personal
credo which is essentially a statement
of life purpose and then think about how
are they living a life consistent with
what they would say their values and
life mission is and then do we fit in it
and so when we started doing that when
we when we told people across America we
will fly you for two days of discussion
and have senior executives there to help
interact that was a huge piece of data
for people that we were that we were
serious and and still all along the way
you know you're just you had to go
through waves of skepticism cynicism
fatigue you know you set a tough budget
and does that mean it's not a village
that it was that reasonably responsive I
think we have time for for one more okay
you can a none citizen call you Katie
yes it's a pleasure having you Katie
it depends what words are in front of
after it can you speak a little bit more
about the disadvantages to having that
stronger the culture specifically for
your leadership role and on a more
personal note for you and for your
citizens how does it how does it having
your daytime job being that touchy-feely
how does that impact your life at home
and your relationship with your own
family whoo I'm the first one which I
think was how does the the strength and
nature of the culture constitute in it
it where's where's it a disadvantage you
know I I can't I've not been asked that
specific question and thinking
spontaneously I really I'm coming up
empty I think it's I think it's a it's
always a good thing now sometimes it
makes some stuff harder because you have
to explain really delicate things that
are uncomfortable but that's sort of
like the bridge you have to pass if you
want a special cultures that's
inevitable so I think it forces
uncomfortable human behavior it forces
you to do stuff and me to do stuff I
might not have the courage to do
otherwise but once you
one of things we tell young leaders is
get out there and talk about your values
out loud to the people that work for you
and it's in tech as a bunch of them will
be looking and saying oh well you think
you live that value you know I'm not so
persuaded and and the power of speaking
out loud so so I think it forces moments
of serious discomfort but it's never a
disadvantage would be my my pretty
strong reaction although I get the
question I'm not trying to be dismissive
and then on the second one yet second
one is I particularly thought provoking
giving my my son my little munchkin is
in the room the but but I believe that
that the divita village has made me a
better human being and and I think you
know I've said my kids have limited
memories of because I was they were ten
and eight when we started this adventure
but but other people who know me
throughout would talk about how its
fostered it's fostered forced encouraged
motivated growth as a human being and I
love most the letters we get from people
that have left or when we give core
value words which we take very very
seriously one of the rituals of our
village the annual core value words and
then they happen throughout the most of
the year are very very serious events
there's no recognition in our night of
honor for business accomplishments it's
all human behavior that that often I
mean for me the most special ones and
often the remarks of the people who get
it will say that I've been at 2v2 six
years and I am a better daddy I'm a
better mommy
I'm a better daughter that's that's what
we're about it's is it for us our
culture is not a part of our business
strategy our culture is about our dreams
of what life should be like and it just
happens to be inserted into a
capitalistic enterprise so so I feel
it's it's why I'm still as my son will a
highly imperfect I think it's made me
way more mindful
at at home and and it's been demanding
as some of you know back 16 years ago
when I took the job I had just come off
a private equity back thing I ran a
company it got taken over was very neat
financially and really sad because we
thought we were building something
special then I did a private equity back
thing with TPG and Bain Capital and it
failed and it failed largely because the
mistakes I made strategically in
otherwise and I had friends who moved
their families across the country to
join this company with me and then a
year and a half later I had to tell them
their job was being eliminated and and
we ended up selling the piece of the
company losing half the money and in the
face of that and I was so I was working
very hard to try to save it and didn't
and and so when I when that was over I
told my wife and kids that I was going
to take six months off and and spend
time with them and get healthier and the
rest and so when search firms a call I
would say you know I'm call me in six
months I'm I'm gonna take some downtime
I was within eight weeks of being done
and then then they called for this
company and since I had run one other
caregiving company before I was the most
professionally fulfilling time in my
life and and so I went through a
hellacious month with my wife Denise who
was also at HBS grad was one of
America's first female venture capital
partners about how much of my taking
this job was ego you want to make some
more money want to prove I can turn on a
company want to run a bigger company
even though it was in another city it
was a total turnaround my family wasn't
going to move versus how much of it was
was virtuous and had to do with having a
positive back to the world and I wasn't
sure about the answer I knew it was a
bunch of both and and clearly we decided
what we did and it was sort of pivotal
in the end was was saying it's Indians
the fact that was going to be difficult
was highly relevant but it's one thing
to be home five nights a week with your
kids and talk to them about leading a
purposeful life and a whole other thing
to be there fewer nights
lead one and and that's the gift that
the village gave me and so and so while
it's pulled me away and certainly
there's times I've been distracted that
I think my kids know that I'm doing my
best to lead a purposeful life and
become a mindful person and I think that
counts for something with them I don't
know well we'll check that out with a
munchkin later yeah all of they all of
the students who are here in order to
get in to the GSB how to answer a
question which has become customary for
us to ask our guests which is what
matters most to you and why I hate
questions like that
the divita people sometimes say well
what matters more you know that keeping
the profits up in the stock price up or
the village and I say as mayor that's a
false dichotomy it's like what's more
important to you air or water you have
to have both I mean to say one's more
important than the other is I think a
paradigm that defies reality and so so I
would say three one is there there is
nothing more special than the people you
love and love you and the older you get
I'm a couple months from 60 the more
significant that that that is and what
you sow so shall you reap you know by
the time you get to my age a lot of
stuff is locked and loaded in terms of
the depth and breadth of your
friendships and the texture of those
friendships and your relationships and
your family and your kids and your
spouse second is to try to become more
mindful each day you know to tread
gently on the planet and the people in
it this is a particularly difficult one
for me but but there's there's a
Buddhist saying that's strictly strictly
speaking there are no spiritual people
there's only spiritual practices and
people who act in a humane mindful
gentle way every day all day
send amazing cumulative ripples through
the course of their life and
so for me that's a it's a particular
challenge and I'm proud of the progress
I've made because it's so important and
then third is the more macro of what
impact you have on the world and
particular people in this room you know
spectacular capabilities spectacular
experiences and and spectacular luck and
getting to come to a place like this
with people like you're sitting with and
so I certainly hope that many of you
take on the incremental responsibility
on top of the first two of trying to
have a significant impact on the world
great great Ansan on all three points
yeah did you have any closing thoughts
you'd like to share with with this crowd
well for me I mean honor to be here I
mean when I was when I was in those
seats of in 1981 to 83 maybe was my
dream that maybe one day I get to come
back and talk to excuse me kids like you
about important topics so for me getting
to be here and be here with Garth and
Charles O'Reilly and Joel Peterson
others is like a dream so I I really
encourage young people think about your
dreams and don't give up on them because
sometimes they come true they are rarely
easy they're rarely linear to go after
but for me many of the dreams I had when
I was your age have come true
and I feel so so lucky and the second
thing I would say is just too with all
the ambitions and the pressures of two
career couples and having babies and you
know been through all that to really
savor the adventure of life there's a
was a French author Colette who who said
I had a wonderful life I only wished I'd
realized it sooner please join me well
thank you